cioè io parlo salve people
allora non dovrei iniziare video dove
faccio vedere che bevo perché non si
beve però questo è burrobirra la
burrobirra si può bere la burrobirra
chissenefrega
ciao belli come è stata la sua d'animo
che sembra solita storia di commenti
non vedo un cazzo sono bella ragazza
come è stato tutto bene allora facciamo
così
siamo agli studios di harry potter
volevo fare questo streaming stasera ma
con la luce è tutto più bello quindi
preferisco farlo adesso è una figata
abbiamo fatto per metà studios quindi
quello che non vedrete sarebbero tipo il
treno l'espresso di hogwards nespresso e
quindi metà studio spi o meno gli
abbiamo già fatti però manca l'altra
meta dove manca diagonale e ci sono un
sacco di altre robe che voglio farvi
vedere se ci siete
venite con me ok basta fare il [ __ ]
visto che c'è gente allora comunque sia
mi sono già siglato tutta la burrobirra
partiamo subito con il 46
questo ti porta in piazza san carlo non
questo è l'autobus quello che si
restringe gli aerei potter questa è
un'area dove hanno racchiuso un sacco di
roba all'aperto quella come questa è la
casa degli zii di harry potter centrale
drive
adesso ve la faccio vedere più da vicino
andiamo a bussare direttamente si
chiamano la polizia
questa si fa la foto la gente ma io sono
più bello e faccio lo streaming sucate
tutti quanti comunque bellissimo
veramente stupendo questo è il ponte se
lo riconoscete sono lo riconoscete c'è
non meritate di vivere prove del ponte
di hogwarts è bellissimo vorrei salirci
però a chi cazzo lascio il telefono solo
dio lo sa
quindi non lo farò e bellissimo beh il
bello è che nel film si vede che tutto
gigante tutto messo tipo traballanti
invece è perfettamente incollato a terra
fantastico c'è anche dei mi saluta
antonio ecco
e bellissimo dove adesso stiamo entrando
in questo stage che credo sia che c'è
non so che cazzo c'è dentro
penso diagonale perché non l'abbiamo
ancora vista
allora questi sono gli scacchi con i
denti non c'e nessuno sulla macchina
devo salire sulla macchina fermi fermi
fermi aspetti ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho
fatta e mi ha la macchina mi ha la
macchina mya di premium visto che non
posso fare una foto perché il telefono
lo uso per farlo streaming tienimi fermo
mentre salgo in macchina centinaio così
la rai
no
[Musica]
lui
l'unica
[Musica]
non posso guidare perché ho bevuto però
vabbè è fighissimo
bellissimo vabbè questa era la macchina
che la volante
questi sono gli scacchi dei maghi
porca eva se son grossi il cavallo più
grosso dei grossi
questo è un pedone fait è mica quanti
erano grossi gli scacchi dei maghi raga
questi sono questi pezzi sono tutti gli
originali tutti tutti ne sono proprio
quelli che hanno usato nel film tutto
quello tutto lo che vedete originale
vi sto facendo questo tour che non so se
potrei fare il problema in questo ma chi
cazzo se ne frega fotte sega viva la
vita
queste sono le boe non lo so però mi
fanno paura soprattutto questa ecco
quando mi sveglio la mattina io questi
capelli ragazze sono gli stessi capelli
di stasera
a parte questo pieno o questa ve la devo
far vedere fermi un attimo a parte
chiara che ride gigante in confronto
agli altri anni è enorme hagrid ma non è
quello guardate questa in teoria star
sta roba
in teoria si dovrebbe un attimo che si
muove ve lo giuro l'ho visto a muoversi
viggiù non vi dico stronzate la magia
esiste ma ciò che ha messo male il
paraorecchi vabbè sticazzi
[Musica]
ok quello è un drago grosso dove ed
hobby highly doppia se facciamo vedere
mica se non facciamo vedere dubbi sono
stronzi dobby ragazzi questo è quello
originale del film ti devi togliere ti
devi toti chi devi togliere grazie ok
bene
proseguiamo allora adesso stiamo per
entrare a diagonale lei quasi
sicuramente sarà lì devono ali e strana
perché è interna non è all'aperto ma
sarà quello il basilisco comunque quello
è un serpen singh molto grosso è proprio
un serpente grossissimo l'ippogrifo per
quanto sembra vero l'ippogrifo che si
muove quanto è vero si muove aspetta non
sono pazzo l'ho visto muoversi più ma si
muoveva prima giuro su dio bambina si
muoveva le distante 2 cazzo giuro
ragazzi prima si muoveva ve lo giuro su
dio e non è stata la birra vi giuro si
muoveva e stranissimo non si sa ma non
si muoveva prima di policoro
non sono io che sono drogato l'ho visto
muoversi va bene ma ogni tanto si
muovono le cose qua a volte nuovo il the
city
signore e signori
[Musica]
e diagonale prima che io faccia un file
della madonna si è out e diagonale
allora abbiamo la gringott che è quella
della miniatura di questo video che è
una bomba
adesso entro li faccio una rapina tre
dei quattro lo faranno là dentro ragazzi
venisse me la sono persa ci sono bambine
tutte quel berretto rosa ce l'abbiamo
anche berretto rosa la timi turner dice
voglio e berretto rosa l'attività
olivander mi sono saltati olivander
abbiamo già comprato le cose ve le
faccio vedere poi in un altro video
ragazzi perché ho contratto la madonna
nello shop comprato la madonna c'era di
tutto ho comprato comprato lo shopping
da tagli gli studios sono miei
ho comprato tutto è figo
ecco quello sono io il sabato sera fu
dio no vabbè
no non ci sto che vede ma come cazzo con
una festa roba che figata si muove la
scopa da sola io pensavo fossero tutti
effetti fatti al computer invece la
maggior parte degli effetti gli fanno
proprio meccanici cioè non sono fatti
sono fatti davvero c'è con i fili una
roba del genere bellissimo fighissimo
con queste diagonale servì a diagonale
vieni denis devo farmi tutti selfin così
perché se no non posso perché sto
facendo lo streaming quindi devo
screenare dopo bene screener o questa
parte dal video per tenermi la foto
pensate avessimo messo bene e ringrazio
denis che mi accompagna e mi dà una mano
un sacco in questo commenta
grazie per le tue spiegazioni senza di
te non so come farei noi siamo a questa
è la parte del concert artists può in
teoria non bisognerebbe far casino
infatti stock è abbastanza zitto ma non
è ke bello pensa che bello avere quel
quadro a casa noi un quadro di wall di
voldemort a casa
non c'è
ok all'inizio ragazzi c'era l'ufficio di
silente che era enorme però non posso
tornare indietro perché è lontanissimo
ma è troppo figo
ok ci sono tutte le scale di hogwarts ma
anche sfigata ecco invece nel presepe di
quel presepe del calcio facciamo questo
nel più fini minchia poi non avete idea
siamo arrivati un ora prima gli studios
per paura che non ci facessero entrare
per per il troppo
[Musica]
a no niente mica mi chiamo aveva visto
che ogni tanto compare qualche fantasma
è stranissimo ave dicevo siamo arrivati
un'ora prima per paura di arrivare in
ritardo invece no siamo grati purtroppo
presto
vabbè si cacci
[Musica]
piangete
piaget e con me
e a piangete da cioè di fi denis dei
fazzoletti denis
ho perso denise acro dovevo persa
devo farmi dei self in questo punto può
finire questo streaming qua per favore
devo fare delle forze devono
necessariamente fare delle foto cazzo
[Musica]
di tanto urlo cazzo perché tanto la
gente che non capisce niente
quindi non vi preoccupate posso anche
dire porca [ __ ] tanto non si capisce
però poi è poi nata su tutti i tutti
italiani guarda questa il mio solito
culo e questo comunque non certo grazie
palo
è veramente assurdo ma gigante ma quanto
cazzo ci hanno messo a farlo più del di
tutti i film
messi insieme il fichissimo
vabbè sentite io vi ho fatto vedere dato
è tutto buio prima che mi copyright in
questo video che la metà basta io direi
che posso concludere qua perché sono
veramente andiamo troppo oltre
[Musica]
niente non in realtà non so che cosa c'è
dopo perché siamo arrivati fino qui ho
fatto vedere questi pezzi in diretta ma
non non siamo ancora andati avanti
mi spiace non hervey fatto vedere
l'espresso di hogwarts perché era un po
indietro ma avete visto roba che merita
era tutto originale del set
c'è una roba incredibile comunque credo
che questo in realtà sia hogwarts quando
facevano le riprese da lontano e rata e
l'hanno ricostruita e poi hanno fatto le
riprese facendo credere che fosse
gigante
invece no è la terra piccola così quando
lo vedete nel film quindi queste awards
quella che avete visto nei film è una
cosa proprio fichissima e io direi che
possono includere qua ragazzi denis per
questa live del tuo incredibile parlato
che ci è stato molto utile
grande come guida turistica lei la
visione
niente sì perché credo vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi vi lascio con questa colonna
sonora certo commento mi piace anche
anche i vari social che come noi video
state in description se dovessi discrete
vi e noi ci vediamo al prossimo vi do un
bacio gay
[Musica]